this is your last chance only 24 hours
left
to lock in your investment into the
biggest grifter on the planet that's
right ladies and gentlemen today we're
talking about the con that continues the
Griff that keeps giving the piss punch
bowl himself Mr Brian Rose of London
real now Brian's full history is way too
long to explain here I have a whole
series documenting this man's long
resume everything from mayor candidate
to bitcoin bro to free speech Warrior
that last one being particularly funny
because his comment section is more
censored than North Korean Wi-Fi but
anyways I recently hit my two year
anniversary of covering Brian and I
realized
I can't stop now so even though London
reel's views have dipped like a real
historian I have to continue documenting
so without further Ado here's the most
recent chapter Brian Rose is selling his
YouTube channel how would you like to
own part of London reel as an equity
investor and join us on our Incredible
Journey of expansion as we transform the
lives of the next one billion people on
the planet with our groundbreaking
broadcast interviews Innovative Online
Academy supercharged Live Events and
forward-looking blockchain strategy well
stay tuned and I will show you how to
partake in this once in a lifetime
opportunity now look when I first found
out about this once in a lifetime
opportunity I was actually too late
somehow I had missed the 27 emails he
sent me asking me to invest and when I
found out it was already over my last
chance for financial Independence had
passed me by so imagine my shock when
Brian extended the deadline 24 hours
just for me I have to admit I also
missed that one but then he did it again
with a limited extension opportunity
which I felt was a bit strange because
as much as I appreciate so many once in
a lifetime opportunities I couldn't help
but think it didn't square with what
Brian said was happening with these
shares flying off the shelves this is
the last day
to buy your shares in London rail we are
closing this process out so you're not
going to have to get any more emails
from me or hear any more messages thank
you for sparing me and uh it's just nuts
over the studio the shares are flying
yeah my favorite part of this whole
video is that the comment section is a
ghost town for such an exciting event I
mean these are all the comments on that
whole video and the most liked one is
why is he looking left to right is he
hunted by someone which the answer to
that is um probably yes he's looking for
all the investors of the digital Freedom
platform uh to see if they want their
money back now of course we know Brian
isn't the first person to try to sell
his YouTube channel as a way to make
money a few weeks ago we covered the
channel disrupt selling a fraction of
their channel for an insane valuation
like 10 million dollars so I wanted to
know how does London real stack up
against that in terms of delusion well I
went to their website and found out
they're trying to raise 1 million pounds
at a pre-money valuation of 14.5
million dollars or sorry pounds we're in
London land which is just insane I mean
this channel barely pulls in a few
thousand views per video and they want
you to believe that they're this
multi-multi-multi-million pound
organization but of course that's why we
need to talk about their road map for
Success see Brian has a three-phase
process which will make everything make
sense see phase one he's going to launch
a London reel crypto token phase two
he's gonna sell his top 10 episodes as
nfts and part of phase three is selling
his top 50 episodes as nfts truly
groundbreaking stuff and all of this is
supposed to generate Revenue that looks
like a Bitcoin hopium chart I mean the
line just goes up according to their
projections they think Lenin real will
make 25 million pounds by 2027. just
like I will be in the 25 million dollar
studio now even if this miracle happens
it's not really clear how much you'll
actually benefit from this profit
because the investor perk section is a
bit vague as to what you'd be entitled
to receive it says you'll get things
like a live stream a share certificate
for the amount you invest but then at
the bottom it says you'll get a chance
to share in the future profits I mean
what do you mean a chance I don't want a
chance I want the profits right if
you're investing in this company I mean
is am I buying a scratch off lottery
ticket and look maybe some of you feel
like I'm splitting hairs here but this
is the exact kind of language that
lawyers use to screw people out all the
time like oh we didn't say you'd get
future profits we said you'd get a
chance for future profits and so I
wanted to look further into this and so
I read their like Financial pitch and
they say that their plan is to pay
dividends based on achieving standard
profitability criteria now what exactly
that means is not really clear I
couldn't find it out it sounds like they
need to make a certain amount of money
uh before you make any money which given
their projections seems like they won't
be hitting it but either way I just
found this whole thing strange like
London reel's Business is already about
selling to London real fans but then
participating in the business is also
selling to London reel fans like this is
in the pitch deck their whole funnel
system of you know look we're a
profitable business look how we get all
these upsell customers but you're kind
of upselling people on investing into
the business right so are you a business
partner or are you the business if you
invest in this thing I think the reason
londonreal has taken such a hit views
wise and credibility wise it's just kind
of because people are so tired of being
constantly sold things I mean I can
remember a time years ago where London
rail was a channel where you could find
interesting people you know talking
about interesting things and maybe you
still can but the amount of grips that
had been started since the vid took over
in 2020 it's just ruined the channel
honestly you have London real courses
you have the freedom platform donation
tribe the Brian for mayor donation Drive
the crypto Academy the equity fundraiser
donation Drive is just always an excuse
to need more money
wait hold on I just got a new email the
London real crowdfunding campaign is
being extended again